colby's got a great opportunity with the
injury to corey kluber he's in the
rotation he's only 22 years old
you have two hits fletcher lines into
the alley left center field that will
split the outfielders and go to the wall
fletch on his way to second and he's
thinking about third though he's gonna
slam on the brakes a lead off double for
david fletcher that's his fifth of the
season
upstairs
so good on elevated pitches fletcher
so here's trout swinging a miss allard
strikes out trout on an elevated
fastball
and his first strike out of the game is
also the first out here's otani
right by him
so he strikes out trout and ohtani in a
very good start
patrick sandoval second start of the
year the first one not a bad one
frazier pulls one toward the left field
corner that's a fair ball nick
they'll go for extra bases
ward comes up firing frazier in there
with a double and here's joey gallows
checks frasier twice slides home the one
two swinging a miss he gets gallow with
a breaking ball and the strikeout ends
the inning going here in the second
inning he's good to go the one-two look
good strike three called and that's his
third strikeout
of the evening
1-1
chopper
up the middle
andrews throws him out and a 1-2-3
pretty efficient for colby allen is off
to a very slow start hitting 107. here's
the 3-2
he swings hits one hard on the ground
right side pulls to his knee knocks it
down flips to sandoval the pitcher
covering but he drops it
so defense a big part of the
conversation yesterday for the angels
and here in the bottom of the second
defense letting him down and the rangers
have a lead off base runner because of
it
nick so lacked the batter
bouncing ball shortstop bobbled again
and everybody's safe
and the angels have just been kicking it
around in this series robinson torinos
now
3-1
trinos off the plate toward fletcher
will flip it to renheifer for one the
relay back at double play
patrick sandoval out to start the bottom
of the third worked around a couple of
errors in the second
good pitch
one down firm 94. you pretty much could
take a pencil and trace the outside of
the strike zone the o2
strike three caught over the outside
corner and frazier knew it so nice pitch
by sandoval
mike trout will lead it off for the
angels as we head to the fourth inning
the one two
swinging a miss a cutter gets trout and
allard strikes him out
for the second time already this evening
lefty ohtani struck out swinging in the
first there's a swing and a miss and he
strikes out ohtani for a second time his
fifth strikeout tonight pretty solid
pitching by kobe
this ball
high in the air out to left field
team play for ref schneider two away
lined up and the delivery
swing and a miss he gets run hippo to
chase a cutter and the strikeout ends
the inning
so allard retires the side in order
getting a sixth strike out of the night
colby allard goes five innings no runs
on two hits six strikeouts
for the lefty torino's up there he
bounced into the double play in that
second inning
and he hits this one on the ground third
could be another double play and indeed
it is five to four to three this time
all right here's frazier a couple of
home runs this year
and he hits his ball hard out into left
field that's a base hit
so another multi-hit game for todd
frazier
he's locked in
yeah he's 13 for his last 34. and now
joey gallo who's oh for two
talking about guys who can change the
score of a game with one swing
this one in the air out to left center
long run for trout he looks up it's gone
gallows done it again a two run homer
off sand the ball
and the rangers at long last on the
board it's two nothing
but he gets a low fastball pops it out
of the ballpark
and
even when he's going bad he's like the
big guys in the middle of the lineup all
it takes is one swing of the bat to
change the game and that's exactly what
he did in that attack gets the ball out
of the park gives the rangers a lead
rodriguez will be the new pitcher for
the reindeer and the payoff
this one hit sharply down to third our
kind of colette has been great down
there and he takes care of rand he fall
one away
trout singled last time up
fletcher first the payoff pitch
strike three call it over the inside
corner
rodriguez downed it up to 94. and now
with a man on first two outs here
it's ian jabo trying to close the door
on anthony rendon and the angels here in
the eighth inning
got him swinging
jabal with a huge strike out of rindon
and the rangers will take that
two-nothing lead to the bottom of the
eight rangers with a two-run lead rafael
montero in to try to get his second save
here's the 1-1
and that's popped up
might be playable tyner falefa has room
and that's the ball game
on back-to-back knights montero with his
first career save yesterday gets another
one today and a two-nothing rangers win